m
[Musique]
que le toit
juste vous êtes de retour avec un nouvel
album en premier album à succès tant way
sept ans pourquoi une si longue absence
j'étais pas partie pour ça puis m année
je sais pas j'ai remettait toujours
cette côté parce que l'industrie où on
est rendu le dise ce que ça veut dire
aujourd'hui ça me faisait peur l'espèce
de thé que ça devienne carrément une
carte de visite comme nous on est un
conte moi plus hautes chaumes depuis le
deuxième album ben ça vaut quand tu
arrives à faire rembourser au moins les
frais du disque mais de penser à créer
quelque chose sachant que ça va sortir
de ta poche plus de temps de repos une
semaine
ben ça fait peur puis safran hippiques
faisait que je traînais beaucoup
beaucoup de la pâte
[Musique]
soucieux
deux rats
vous avez mentionné votre chambre ce
fait 30 ans que j'attends son
élaboration artistique hyper important
oui et vous chantez encore beaucoup
l'amour sur votre dernier jeu c'est oui
mais non mais c'est vraiment à votre
direction
ça me colle à la peau non oui ben écoute
sont encore à 100 après 30 ans c'est
parce qu'il ya de l'amour le oui c'est
vrai qu'on sent dans beaucoup de textes
parce que la plupart des gens qui ont
écrit pour moi nous connaissent kaunas
notre histoire et en a même certains qui
connaissent notre rencontre fait que ça
fait des belles chansons puis oui et
puis l amour forme d'amour houcine à
l'album i l amitié et amour entre un
frère et soeur lorsque vous avez annoncé
la sortie de votre nouvel album
la réaction du public est assez immédiat
wali billets pour les concerts se
vendent très bien mais est-ce que vous
aviez pas qu'on vous oubliez un peu avec
cette longue absence de se7en ah oui ben
oui même des fois quand je passe sur
scène pendant un mois
c'est fou hein mais fait quoi sept ans a
fait pas
oui j'avais peur je n'avais pas de ça ou
si j'avais par deux depuis être capable
de faire l'entrevue les premiers bruits
pourquoi ben je sais pas d'avoir trop
d'affaires à dire et en même temps dès
la première question savons jamais la
preuve pose une question puis écoute
j'ai pu tisser les bus qui exigerait
compères la façon de faire les choses ou
une question de confiance pis ça se perd
vite dans ce métier là parce qu'on a
besoin du public ou d'un retour si tu
veux du public pour garder sa intact ou
le pourtant toute cette insécurité de la
dernière fois que je vous ai vu en
conscience et avec harry chelsy
marie-hélène thibert et martine st clair
j'étais vraiment en voiles noirs quel
est votre secret peau malgré le temps
qui passe garder cette voix grave et
puissante qui donne la graphique sans
mon corps non non il y en a eu
en plus il le fait qu'en vieillissant je
prends plus je pense que j'ai plus en
forme aujourd'hui que je l'étais à 25
ans ça c'est sûr donc que je cours
ce samedi garde saine d'esprit surtout
puis en même temps ben forcément ça aide
tout le reste vous courez au point de
faire du marathon oui mais là j'en ai
pas fait depuis le dernier marathon
auquel je me suis inscrit je peux aller
le coup non ouais je sais trop ce sujet
je sais mais j'ai quand même fait le
training jusqu'à la dernière semaine
puis maintenant je cours depuis 2006
j'ai fait huit marathons mais bon j'ai
pas toujours sorti attaque de feu
[Musique]
parce que l'image de lucio silla filles
de porter le c pour l'instant les
gendarmes ont fait ça gueule puis je
trouve
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ag as
[Musique]
avant de faire cette entrevue rencontré
un collègue de travail qui lie les deux
fois changé ma vie dans son rôle de
marge en annonçant magna je vis le
dernier journaliste grâce à elle
juste du fou est ce que vous êtes encore
attache à ce personnage là mais j'ai
encore la run j'ai encore les bois
encore les langues encore le souci que
je vais même pas un
c'est vraiment je pourrais avoir une
infection due mais j'ai gardé tout
s'échangeait encore mont bleu il avait
plein de trucs
[Musique]
ah j'ai tellement eu nous faire seul et
je chante encore les chansons de
l'argent enfin je garde toujours un
petit jean paul ii dans 100% foot
roulant mais je sais que ça fait plaisir
aux gens moi ça me fait presser sames et
coton je les fait 510 fois pieds j'ai
encore besoin de 12 des fois bien tu de
vous un sur cinq pour beaucoup le disent
et avertissements j'ai trop parlé
l'epita ligne